in reality entrepreneurs do everything
they can to minimize risk the first
thing you want to do is define the
market that you're going after that it's
not the size of the circle that matters
but knowing its boundaries so if you
don't truly think it's something that
you would yourself be a customer off
don't try to pitch it the single biggest
advantage a value investor has is not IQ
it's patience and waiting avoid the use
of spreadsheets and avoid precision
thinking and that's no fun it's not fun
to hit your head against a brick wall so
what you want is a business that has a
deep moat with lots of piranhas in it
and that's getting deeper by the day I'm
flexible I think it's very important in
investing to be a learning machine pay a
lot of close attention to the feedback
you get from the people who are
listening to the pitch he's an Indian
American investor businessman and
philanthropist he sold his company
Transtech Inc in 2000 for twenty million
dollars today he is a managing partner
of pub rye investment funds he's Mohnish
Pabrai and here are his top ten rules
for success people think that
entrepreneurs take risk and they get
rewarded because they take risk in
reality entrepreneurs do everything they
can to minimize risk they are not
interested in taking risk they want free
lunches and they go after free lunches
and so if you study on any number of
entrepreneurs from Ray Kroc - you know
herb Schultz at Starbucks and - even
even Buffett and Munger and so on what
you'll find is that they have repeatedly
made bets which are low risk bets which
have high return possibilities so
they're not going high risk high return
they're going low risk high return and
even with Bill Gates for example the
total amount of capital that ever went
into Microsoft was less than fifty
thousand between the time it started and
today that's the total amount of capital
that went into the company so Microsoft
you cannot say was a high risk venture
because they
no capital deployed but it had high
uncertainty bill gates could have gone
bankrupt or Bill Gates could have ended
up the wealthiest person on the Forbes
400 and he ended up at the extreme end
of the bell curve and that's fine but he
did not take risk to get there he was
comfortable with uncertainty so
entrepreneurs are great at dealing with
uncertainty and also very good at
minimizing risk that's the classic great
entrepreneur if you look at any market
any product any market they will
typically be three or four players at
the most that control 80% of that market
and it could be making airplanes or it
could be making you know hair clips you
can pretty much go across the board it
could be making software anything you
want and and you know I found that
stunning you know and and if you invert
that so one of my heroes Charlie Munger
says you know every time you encounter
something always invert the logic to try
to get some other place so if you invert
that principle first of all if you agree
with the principle then you know then
the inversion would be that if you're
starting a business and you say that
this is a ten billion dollar market and
I just need 10% of it and I'll be a
billion dollar company well right there
you're off because the inversion would
be that if you're going after a market
you're your approach has to be how do I
get sixty percent of that market and so
if your starting point is that I'm going
to take two percent of this market or
five percent of this market what you
have not done is you have not segmented
that market properly and that is a fatal
flaw so the first thing you want to do
is define the market that you're going
after and after you've defined it if you
don't get to very clear-cut game plan to
get 50 60 percent market share then
don't even try because either you have
not done
job correctly or you don't have anything
to offer that is going to be that
compelling to people I think another
another very important straight for
successful investing is to stay within
your circle of competence so I think
Buffett always says that it's not the
size of the circle that matters but
knowing its boundaries it's absolutely
critical and you know Charlie Munger
talks about that he gives a couple
examples one is he says that if in a
small town you bought the McDonald's
franchise you bought the Ford dealership
Ford dealership gas station not so good
and gas station we leave the Patels
low-cost operations okay and then then
you want the best class a office
building and you want the best
residential building right so if you've
got these four assets and you don't need
to own them completely you could own 20%
of each of them right so his perspective
was that if in Peoria Illinois you own
these four assets and you just sat on
them for your whole life you would end
up probably quite wealthy and so if you
think about it from a you know Modern
Portfolio theory point of view you would
say well you're not diversified
everything's in one geography etcetera
etcetera
yeah but the odds I'd broadly still work
out and in fact he has a friend here in
near Stanford John Arriaga who all he
did was bought real estate within a mile
of the Stanford campus and you know I
think Arriaga the billionaire and so you
know what is their Yeager circle of
competence you know it's this small so
the size of the circle is not relevant
staying inside the circle is very
fundamental do not try to sell something
that you wouldn't buy yourself okay so
if you don't truly think it's something
that you would yourself be a customer of
don't try to pitch it you know don't be
a used-car salesman so please make sure
that whatever you're trying to come up
with is compelling enough that you would
yourself deeply be deeply interested in
buying that product
so you know charlie munger likes to say
that you don't make money when you buy
stocks and you don't make money when you
sell stocks you make money by waiting
and so the biggest the single biggest
advantage a value investor has is not IQ
it's patience and waiting waiting for
the right pitch and waiting for many
years for the right pitch so what's that
saying of Pascale that you like about
just certainly yeah all man's misery
stemmed from his inability to sit in a
room alone and do nothing and all I'd
like to do to adapt Pascal is all
investment managers misery's stem from
the interpreter tea to sit alone in a
room and do nothing the way the way to
really look at investing is that when
when you look at again a business like
Google or Microsoft or Berkshire you
really have to put yourself in the shoes
of the people running the business and
you have to ask yourself how do they run
the business do they run it through a
set of spreadsheets or how do they run
it and I and I would bet that most of
these businesses are run in a manner
where the founders or CEOs are really
looking at kind of three to five
variables that dominate most of the
their thinking and outcome and direction
and so as an investor
you've got to hone in on those same
variables so if you can get to the same
variables if you want to invest in
Microsoft you can get to the same
variables that Satya Nadella is using
and if you and Google you get to the
same variables that Larry and Sergey are
using then you're getting very close to
trying to figure out what the business
might do and and from there you can
extrapolate whether it's under priced or
fairly priced and so on so that's what I
would suggest is avoid the use of
spreadsheets and avoid precision
thinking the stronger the marketing the
weaker the sales engine can be okay so I
do not consider myself a good salesman
I consider myself a poor salesman I
consider myself a pretty strong
marketing person and so if you have done
your marketing homework you can be a
leper and make sales and a standing
example of that is someone in front of
you because basically my my approach to
sales would be you know 180 degrees
opposed to your traditional used car
salesman schmoozing model and golf
courses and all that you know none of
that is of much interest to me so the
stronger the marketing the less
important to sales engine become so it
is very important in my opinion to spend
incredible amounts of time on the
marketing aspect of the business because
if you don't spend that time on that
aspect of it you will spend 50x at that
time on the sales end and hit your head
against a brick wall and that's no fun
it's not fun to hit your head against a
brick wall so it's good not to go there
so so I just feel the stronger the
marketing the weak of the sales now
quickly define moats
in terms of a business that keeps
competition away well you know if you
talk to Michael Porter he would give you
five books on what is meant by you know
strategy and competitive advantage and
durable competitive advantage and if you
talk to Warren and Charlie they will
just say it's a moat and they'd break it
down to one one word but basically it's
the ability of a business to have some
type of and some type of an enduring
competitive advantage that allows it to
earn a better than average rate of
return over an extended period of time
and so some businesses have narrow moat
some have broad modes
some have modes that are deep but get
filled up pretty quickly so what you
want is a business that has a deep moat
with lots of piranhas in it and that's
getting deeper by the day
that's that's a great business I'm
flexible I think it's very important in
investing to be a learning machine and
to have flexibility and to be willing to
look at the the opportunity set and
decide whether you need to do anything
at all
or what is the best thing you can do
based on the available opportunities
let's say you have come up with a
compelling value proposition let's say
you're absolutely truthful you truly
understand it and your pitch is truthful
and all of that what I have found is
that is that basically whatever you come
up with and you know you've come up with
it in your lab and thinking about it
talk of friends looks great it's the
service of product looks great the real
litmus test of that is when you put it
in front of customers right so when you
go out and make your page you create an
ad or whatever else and a very very
important thing for a entrepreneur to do
is when they put that out there be very
very pay a lot of close attention to the
feedback you get from the people who are
listening to the pitch and this is very
important at the front end because what
is probably the case is that whatever
you came up with is off base it's not
exactly what your market yawns and you
know I'll give you example there's a
friend of mine in Chicago and he started
this company called InstallShield and
many of you might be familiar with a
company and you're installing different
windows products installed she'll comes
up and we're ish basically was like I
think 19 years old or something when he
came up with installed shield and he
said you know he went to a trade show he
was going to go to a trade show some
software tools trade show and he was
turned to a whole bunch of different
things he was rented with Google Maps 30
30 years ago you know when there was no
way that the computing could could
support that sort of thing but he went
illustrate you and he had created this
kind of you know tradeshow booth with
the different products and he had seven
products seven different tools that he
was pitching and it wasn't balancing on
that booth he wanted to put four bullets
on one side and four bullets on the
other and he was like four and three so
he was it was really bothering him and
so as an afterthought
this little tool he had was just to
install software for installing software
was his eighth bullet he just put that
in the end at the bottom the eight ball
it was installed software installation
tool and throughout the whole week was
goes I think a couple of days ago that
this trade show booth all these people
are coming by and all the stuff going on
and there was a guy across the aisle
from him who spent two days looking at
those eight pins because he he was in
the software business and after two days
he came up to and said you know that
product I have an interest in that
product and this product did not exist
it was in voracious mind and so this was
one of the only leads he picked up at
the show so he went back and created the
product and gave it to the guy and then
he found that other people wanted it and
so on so forth okay so bottom line is
that as you study if you study startups
you will find over and over that what
actually works is not what you actually
came up with what actually worked is
again on some tangent or some kind of UX
you mentioned something to a customer
and passing and then they grab on to
that day you know I want that you say oh
he's unusual he wants a usual thing I
should keep a core pitch know what you
really have to do is pay really close
attention to what is going on thank you
so much for watching I made this video
because Caesar V asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of the
top ten rules had the biggest impact on
you and why leave it in the comments
I'll join the discussion thank you so
much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon